le petit prince commence à part visiter
les planètes voisines pour y chercher
une occupation et pour s'instruire
c'est l'histoire d'un voyage celui du
petit prince d'antoine de saint-exupéry
le raconte en 1943 un an avant sa mort
l'oim d'imaginer l'héritage que
constituera ce conte philosophique à
travers les âges ma fleur est là quelque
part mais si longtemps on mange la fleur
c'est pour lui comme si brusquement
toutes les étoiles s'éteignait en 93
pages le petit prince rencontre de roi
larose l'ivrogne et toute une galerie de
personnages chacun raconte l'absurde et
le vis des grandes personnes mises en
lumière par la naïveté du petit prince
en récit apporter humaniste selon le
scénariste claude s'en tenir comme il
l'expliqué en 1962 saint-exupéry avait
compris je crois que posséder le monde
appartient - aux militaires malgré
toutes leurs forces aux politiciens
malgré tout leurs habiletés
disons même n'appartient pas tellement
aux adultes avec toute leur science et
toute leur puissance mais plutôt la
vraie possession du monde total et
désintéressé appartient aux enfants
l'enfance dans ce qu'elle a de plus pur
le petit prince en est une réminiscence
pour le lecteur comme le racontait le
roman c'est pierre schoendoerffer en
1970 la nostalgie
je crois que j'étale cet ami s'est pas
petit enfant le petit prince états est
un rêve et l'innocence et de cvg c'est
quelque chose de perdu je crois qu'on ne
peut pas vivre innocemment
je crois que la vie à vie lit on n'est
jamais tout à fait la hauteur de ses
rêves
le petit prince et dans un premier temps
destinée à un jeune lectorat c'est pour
lui une porte d'entrée vers la
philosophie
à l'instar de cette phrase on ne voit
bien qu'avec le coeur
voici ce qu'elle inspirait à des jeunes
lecteurs en 1983
par exemple si quelqu'un les horribles
comme routier par exemple voter s'ils
horrible et ben en fait que tous les
enfants l'adorent parce qu'il est très
gentil les ja du coeur quoi le petit
prince a traversé les âges et des
frontières plus de 300 traductions ont
fait du récit de saint-exupéry un
langage universel
[Musique]